-We are honored to have
our first guest with us tonight.
He served for 36 years
as a senator from Delaware.
He was Vice President
under the Obama Administration,
and now he serves as the 46th
President of the United States.
This is his first time
on a late night program
as the sitting president.
Please welcome
President Joe Biden!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ The Roots play
"Hail to the Chief" ]
[ Laughs ] Yes!
-Hey, Jimmy.
How are you, man?
-[ Laughs ]
President Biden,
I appreciate you being here.
It's your first time on our show
as President Biden,
and I'm honored.
-I'm honored to be on.
Thanks for inviting me.
-We have lots to talk about.
Let's start with
some good news here.
You passed
your infrastructure bill.
This is a big deal.
Passed!
What are some changes
that Americans can expect
from passing the bill?
-Well, you know, we used to be
the number one,
have the best infrastructure
in the world --
highways, bridges,
the whole works.
And now we rank number 13
in the world.
And that has a lot
to do with quality of life.
It has a lot to do
with whether or not
we're going to be competitive.
For example,
one thing it does --
we're going to replace
all the lead pipes in America
that are causing people
to get sick, get cancer,
and kids to be able
to drink clean water.
We're going to make sure
that we have
everywhere in the country,
rural and urban and suburban,
we have Internet connections.
Because the world is changing,
and we're so far
behind the curve.
But the big thing
it's going to do,
it's going to create
millions of jobs,
and it's going to change
the quality of life
for an awful lot of people
around the country.
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's great.
And I know you've been
working hard
on the Build Back Better Plan.
-Yes.
-Some people may not
fully understand
what's actually in this plan.
Is there a simple way
to break it down?
-Yeah.
What's in it is the ability
for working class
and middle class people
to have the cost of living
cut significantly.
For example, there's money
in there to make sure
that there is the ability
to care for childcare.
Right now,
if you're in New York
and you're a man or a woman
having childcare
for your children,
you're paying $21,000 to $25,000
a year to be able to do that.
Well, most people can't do that,
so people leave the work force.
This will mean you don't have to
pay more than 7% of your income,
saving tens of thousands
of dollars over time.
We also provided an ability,
Build Back Better Initiative,
we're going to make sure
you're able to send
your 3- and 4- and 5-year-olds
to school,
which will increase
exponentially
their chance of succeeding.
All of the studies show, Jimmy,
that 47% better chance
of graduating from high school,
no matter what the background
you come from,
no matter what home
and to be able to go on
to get to school.
What better can happen
for America
than have a better
educated population?
-Absolutely.
-There's a whole range
of things that are in there
that are going to really reduce,
essentially,
the cost of living for people
in a reasonable, rational way.
And by the way, every single bit
of that bill is paid for.
No one making
less than $400,000 a year
will pay
an additional cent in taxes,
as well as it will not increase
the deficit one penny.
-Do you think this will pass
the Senate before the year?
-Well, I hope it will.
I don't have a single Republican
vote right now to pass it.
And, uh --
-Wow!
-So, it's going to be tough,
but I think we can get it done.
If we don't get it, I'm going to
keep at it until we get it done.
-I was at the Kennedy Center,
and I saw Republicans
and Democrats in the crowd.
Everyone was laughing at jokes
and listening to great music.
And everyone seemed
cordial and nice.
And I go, "This seems like
this should be much easier
to get along with everybody."
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Well, Jimmy, look,
the truth is
that before COVID hit,
the Trump arm
of the Republican Party,
which seems to be
the Republican Party now,
did not even show up
at the Kennedy Center.
They wouldn't go to the awards.
So all the people you have
that we saw at that event,
which was a very fulsome event,
were people who in fact
are Republicans,
but they're the kind --
like for example,
a lot of Republicans
and Democrats
used to get
really on well together.
For example, one of the reasons
I was a little bit late
coming on
is because -- not coming on,
but to do the taping here,
is because
I did Bob Dole's eulogy today.
He asked me on his deathbed
whether I would do his eulogy.
We were friends. We disagreed,
but we were friends.
We used to have an awful lot
of that relationship,
and it still exists,
except that the Qanon
and the extreme elements
of the Republican Party
and what Donald Trump
keeps sort of, seems to me,
feeding, you know,
with the big lie,
it makes it awful hard.
And I think most Republicans --
there's an awful lot
of Republicans in Congress
I think would agree with that.
-Yeah, I thought it was great
to see you there.
We gave you a standing ovation
because I go, "Here he is.
He's bringing class back.
He's a classy guy."
And you're bringing class
back to the office.
-You're very kind to say that.
-And I thought it was amazing
that you did that.
-Thank you.
-The COVID problem.
I don't know what else to do,
and how to tell people
to get the vaccine.
At this point, I think people
are going to do
what they will, I guess.
I don't know what to say.
Is it the youth
that we have to hope
the kids get us out of this?
Because, I mean, I got vaxxed,
I got boosted,
I got whatever you got.
If you want me to wear
red pants,
I'll wear red pants.
I want this thing to go away.
-Well, I think what we ought
to do is have more people
listen to your song.
-Yeah that's what
I'm talking about, yeah.
[ Applause ]
-I think that will
get them moving.
-I gotta tell you --
So I had this song come out,
it's called "It Was
a Masked Christmas" this week,
with Ariana Grande
and Megan Thee Stallion, and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
You were nice enough
to tweet about it --
"'Tis the season
(to get boosted)."
This is amazing
that the president did this.
I am so excited
that you did this.
It changed everything.
All these radio stations
want the song.
Now they're playing the song.
But you said
in another comment,
you said the message
is very important --
get your booster.
-Well, it is.
It's really important, Jimmy.
Look, we're so far ahead
of the rest of the world
in terms
of the science and technology
to produce the vaccines.
And now we found out that
if you have your two shots
for Moderna or from Pfizer
or the one shot from J&J,
what happens is,
this booster shot
not only brings
the levels back up of immunity,
I mean, to deal with fighting
off the virus,
any of the viruses,
but it brings it up
exponentially.
So if you want to be sure
you're going to be okay --
And the other good news, Jimmy,
is that we now have
5-, 6-, and 7-year-olds
are able to be vaccinated,
as well as teenagers.
And so we're moving.
We're moving.
Now, I don't,
the politicalization of this,
making it become
a political statement
if you get the shot and somehow,
I don't know what the h--
Anyway.
[ Laughter ]
Here's the deal, Jimmy.
The bottom line is that the way
to avoid this virus
is to get two shots
and then get the booster shot.
It's available.
We have the medicines available.
It will make
a gigantic difference.
And even if you don't care
so much about yourself,
think about your kids,
your brother,
your sister, your co-worker.
And this stuff about Biden
is mandating
these things happening
and it's un-American,
look at it this way --
it's patriotic to get this done.
Not a joke.
It's patriotic to get it done.
-Yeah.
Do you, um, how much do you pay
attention to approval ratings?
-Well, not anymore.
I'm joking.
[ Laughter ]
I was paying attention
when it was in the mid 60s.
Now I'm in the mid 40s,
I don't pay attention.
-I appreciate the honesty,
yeah.
I mean, because you came in --
you came in hot.
And then you got to medium,
but now you're at a low.
But you've just got to keep
your head down, right,
and just keep
doing the right thing?
-Well, look, here's the deal.
I think that it's --
We've been in less than a year.
A lot has happened.
And look, people are afraid.
People are worried.
And people are getting so much
inaccurate information to them.
I don't mean about me,
but about the situation.
And so, you know, they're being
told that, you know,
Armageddon is on the way.
The truth is, the economy
is growing more than it has
any time in close to 60 years.
The unemployment rate
is down to 4.2%.
It's going to go lower,
in my view.
We do have inflation on things
that in fact matter
to people's lives.
You know, when you show up
at a gas station
and it's $3.50 at your pump,
although now because
I took 50 million barrels,
I called the oil petroleum
reserve,
the gasoline is down below $3
in many places.
It's going to come down.
It's going to move.
But in the meantime,
people are worried.
And they're worried about
whether or not
they have a brother,
sister, uncle, aunt
who has gotten COVID,
and they don't know
what to do about it.
I mean, so there is
a lot of anxiety,
and my job is to be
straightforward,
shoot from the shoulder,
let people know exactly
what the truth is,
and lay out how I'm going to try
to make life better for them.
-Yeah. Does anyone really
understand how hard your job is?
Like, who, I mean --
besides my uncle, apparently,
who knows everything.
He knows everything.
But I mean --
-Well, send him over.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no, you don't
want to talk to this guy.
[ Laughter ]
But I mean, even just being
in D.C. the other day
and driving around,
you see all these giant
buildings and you just --
you feel kind of nervous
and you feel like --
I feel important when I'm there,
but you're the leader
of our country.
I mean, the pressure.
And then you have to do
20 events
during the day
that we don't even see.
-Well, look, I was
Vice President for eight years.
I knew what the job was,
and I don't --
no one should feel sorry for me.
It's the greatest honor anybody
can have in their whole life,
in my view, is to be
President of the United States.
But what the difference is --
the difference is that
when you're in Congress --
and I had important jobs
in the Congress as a senator.
I was chairman
of important committees.
But being President is like
being chairman
of every single committee.
Nothing gets to my desk unless
it hasn't been able to be solved
before it got to my desk.
So by definition,
it's more difficult.
Harry Truman had a great line.
He said about being president,
he said, "The buck stops here."
I used to be -- I kid at Barack,
President Obama,
who was a good friend
and we served eight years
as friends together.
And I used to say to him --
instead of him thanking me,
I got to be the last guy
in the room to give him advice.
That was the deal we had.
And he'd thank me, and I get
to walk out and say, "Look,
I give you the advice,
you got to make the decision."
-Yeah.
-"And, you know, what happens
is going to be on you."
But that's part of the deal.
But look, I have
enormous confidence --
You're going to realize
what a naive guy I am.
But I really have faith
at the end of the day
the American people
are going to get it.
They understand.
Given half a shot,
they have never, ever, ever,
ever let the country down.
We've just to give them a shot.
-That's right.
More with President Joe Biden
when we come back, everybody.